wir besuchen heute das Takumi in
Düsseldorf Papa plattes
Lieblingsrestaurant ein japanisches
rahmenrestaurant auf der Immermannstraße
mitten in Little Tokio ein extrem
authentisches Restaurant hier gibt es
Rahmen wie in Japan und das Merkmal also
finden wir heraus was Kevin dort ist und
lassen wir es uns gut schmecken hier
sitzen jetzt Kevin was ist deine Go2
Bestellung ich glaube das ist die
wichtigste Frage wenn wir in deinem
Lieblings Restaurant sind also wir haben
hier nur eine vegetarische ähm das heißt
die bestelle ich und die rosa das ist
immer die Bestellung eigentlich überall
wo ich am Essen die aber Familie in Köln
ne sehr geil ich fühle das auch das
beste wirklich was man in Köln bekommen
kann aber hier ist man halt quasi in
Japan so ne sagen ja nicht umsonst immer
man Straße Japan town so das ist halt
einfach so authentisch hier und so gut
hier ich weiß nicht gibt's in Japan
keine Ahnung
auf die Karte gucken vielleicht
entdecken wir noch die eine oder andere
vegetarische
Spezialitäten gegessen habe ich die
surfen
die waren so brutal
wir haben da bricht noch immer so eine
Miso ist ja trotzdem so kräftig ich
glaube der vermisst man auch wirklich
nichts auch wenn man Fleisch ist deshalb
bin ich gespannt auf die so auf jeden
Fall spicy Bro das ist so wichtig muss
auch immer ein Klassiker ist halt noch
jeder Name dazu ja eigentlich noch
machen eigentlich ja ist immer sehr sehr
geil ich wünschte die hätten in dem
Laden das wäre die einzige Sache noch
besser werden
so krank weißt du was ich trotzdem gerne
bestellen will Mini Curryreis weil wir
haben ja immer das Video gemacht über
das angeblich beste Gericht der Welt das
ist direkt um die Ecke also japanisches
Curry und das war so lecker ich finde
das sieht verloren aus aber es wurde auf
seiner Plattform Taste Atlas und Nummer
eins weltweit also durch durch User baut
quasi krass aber ich glaube unsere
Bestellung steht was leckeres zu trinken
dazu aus stellen das ganze und dann
sehen wir uns zum Essen ich freue mich
sehr darauf also ich bin froh dass wir
dieses Restaurant
[Musik]
das hat Kevin bestellt ramune wäre es
nicht kennt ja das hat nämlich einen
kleinen
drin genau
jetzt schmeckt das noch Wasser jetzt ist
es geöffnet ist einfach geöffnet
[Musik]
noch ein bisschen mehr bestellt wir
haben erstmal hier die Rahmen man sieht
die trübe nie so Brühe innen drin alle
möglichen Einlagen Pack Joy Chili
Frühlingszwiebeln Kaiserschoten no joke
es sieht richtig richtig gut aushalten
genau
[Musik]
boah boah believe von innen oder
wirklich das ist so finde das immer
wieder krass dass so eine Suppe so ein
Geschmack selber einführen kann
spicy sehr scharf
ich weiß nicht muss man halt erstmal
rein mixen es gibt so einen zu scharf wo
man so eine Pause machen muss und das
hasse ich und hier ist perfekt
dann einfach nur noch nach scharf
schmecken so das hast
schmeckt so ne also noch weiter
Digger die machen einfach alles richtig
machen kann so die kompletten Einlagen
so ein bisschen frischen noch aber
trotzdem schon so blanchiert vorgekocht
auch so eine geile Menge für mich das
ist so perfekt einfach so eine Beilage
gerade ich mache auch ein
Gutscheine super Leid volle Erfahrung
und Erinnerung
hat das mal gemacht ganz viele Küchen
auch schon ausprobiert und als ich dann
gegessen hatte weil es gab nichts
anderes mehr zu Hause
Hunger und das war das einzige was noch
da war und ich hatte die ganze Zeit
keine Ahnung und dann war so dieses so
ich muss was essen und dann ist dieses
Kind hier und dabei hatte ich aber dann
wieder übelst die Zahnschmerzen
ich kann es auch schwer bewerten aber es
sieht übelst geil aus solche füttern
normalerweise
richtig sauer richtig lecker
lass uns wichtig wichtig
unter der Woche und geht kurz Nachladen
Eröffnung wir sind glaube ich so 12:30
Uhr hier gewesen und dann hat das echt
gut funktioniert
die geile Sau Alter
süß ist dabei diese knusprige Seite und
rasiert perfekt mit der weißen Seite
brauche ich jetzt nicht besser
formulieren können man will immer mehr
davon essen ich glaube das ist generell
so ein Komfort Q so 100 %
zu Hause machen ne hat mir auch mal so
hier in den hier so direkt zum
japanischen Laden nebenan hier und dann
kannst du dir so übel geil auch so ein
illogiose einfach wechseln also so viel
Tiefkühlfach holen aber zu Hause machen
und dann sagt meinst du dass du PKW
kaufen
selbst machen
[Musik]
denn das allererste Video das Erik
geschnitten hat bei persönlicher Koch
Kevin wirklich geil
also juni vor zwei Jahren noch ungefähr
ich werde dieses erstmal so geil ne
manchmal heute noch zurück wirklich geil
ich habe nie wieder so ein gutes
gegessen geil trotzdem hast du mir nicht
den einen Punkt mehr gegeben mit dem ich
beim Promi Dinner alleine gewonnen hätte
haha
wir sehen uns gleich wieder
probieren wir auch das also das Curry
das japanische mit so ein bisschen
Klebereis und dieser herzhaften dicken
Soße das sieht viel geiler aus als auf
der Karte oder ja auf jeden Fall Kamera
verstehen nach wie vor nicht wie das ist
Nummer eins Gericht der Welt sein kann
weil für mich gibt's besser die sind
auch immer geistig bisschen mscreen wow
alles wirklich sehr sehr lecker es ist
wirklich sehr gut alles davon ist auch
gut ne also Kimchi jeder Name aber Hage
alles ich glaube der einzige ist so dass
man halt wenn man wirklich nicht
pünktlich kommt muss man leider anstehen
kann
sehr gerne zu Hause selbst machst wie
groß ist der andere Teil des
selbstkochens so zu Hause bei dir
Kevin und ich haben ja mitgemacht beim
perfekten Promi Dinner und da hat Kevin
wirklich überrascht mit seinem Kochen ja
ich habe aber als Hauptspeise gemacht
also quasi die hinter der Kamera sitzt
die stellt dann immer so fragen mit
denen die dich dann pusht in eine
Richtung wo du Antworten sollst auf die
Frage noch mal auf und das heißt
dann muss ich sagen ja ich finde das
magst du uns ein paar schon ist weil und
so können die halt dann so ein bisschen
so das Lenken auf jeden Fall Kevin dann
so ich glaube acht oder neun von zehn
gegeben oder sowas für das Essen für den
Abend und die Realisation wirklich
sicher ist wirklich so
wirklich so viel Punkte geben
wo du so eine Küche aufpassen irgendwie
drauf gebaut aktuell ist meine Küche
einfach nur von Obi bei so malerböcke
und damit es in der Mitte nicht
durchhängt sind da so Umzugskarton
runter und so eine Amazon 150 €
Herdplatte das ist alles was ich habe
die ersten anderthalb Jahre wo ich so 4k
und Koch Videos gemacht habe ich nur auf
diesen mobilen Induktionsplatten gekauft
die sind eigentlich geil ne die werden
schnell heißt du hast keinen Film mega
scheiße
dann habe ich nur ein halb großen
Kühlschrank weil ich ja gesagt habe hey
wenn ich eine Küche bekomme
Einbaukühlschrank also hole ich
übergangsweise
am Dienstag machen wir in meiner Küche
ein Kochlöffel bei Kevin auf dem deshalb
unbedingt vorbei schauen ich bin
gespanntheiten
machen müssen
wir haben alles aufgegessen es war
unfassbar lecker ein Traum Kevin
gezeigt hast bzw noch mal gezeigt hast
und auch angezeigt dass sie wirklich
sehr zu empfehlen sind zum nächsten
Video wieder Dienstag ist der Stream bis
dahin ciao